mellifera I in in the in the proper
sense of it I believe in you know we are
our brothers keepers not not in in the
sense of communism but that an a wealthy
civilized country has an obligation to
take care of its less fortunate and to
provide a safety net for everybody I
believe in democracy in the broad sense
that we should be of a shared political
vision there was a time when I was very
young when I flirted with conservatism I
think it's a phase that people go
through it seems you could see they were
there were excesses and he looked and
but it didn't last very long and the
only thing I would say is I think I had
become I don't know that my politics
have changed mother much but my but I
had become more political because when I
was when I was in my 20s maybe even when
I was in my 30s I could imagine that
policy was really a matter of
intelligent discussions between people
and the best ideas would automatically
prevail and well that's not the way it
is it's there are discussions among
intelligent people but you have to you
have to do more than just you know being
being right there's nowhere near enough